should I read this question because this
is a question for echo Charles so that
means I guess yeah well this part of
it's two questions actually but I put
them together because they're pretty
close Jaakko willing what brought you
and echo Charles together can we get the
backstory there I liked the chemistry
echo Charles question for you to answer
on Jocko podcast what have you learned
from Jocko and how has your life changed
since this is echos first response to a
question don't screw it up here we go
chuckle you yeah of course which is
funny because that's kind of how what
brought us together or part of what
brought us together
and I think it's good that I answered
this part because you probably remember
a lot less of it so I would say it was
oh six I see I had seen you like the
first you know whatever within the first
year of of joining with Dean in Oh five
but I didn't know you didn't talk to you
nothing like that I just had heard of
you from Dean um and then in like oh six
when we moved over to the boxing club I
rolled with you one time I was still a
white belt and so they could have been
still oh five I don't know and then you
know you beat me up and you kind of you
were just more like this stoic guy BC I
would imagine the same guy that people
interpret you to be from the outside you
know how like not intense but just real
like oh yeah just real matter of fact
you know so he beat me up or whatever
and then I was so I since I had already
heard you you were Dean's black belt and
you know all this stuff that I was like
yeah that's about right you know he's
you know good you just do whatever beat
me up but that wasn't really saying much
because everyone was beating me up and
then um time went on I ain't see you for
a while and then um when I started to
kind of get go so I was training with
Brent
remember Brenton yeah I was training
with him and then with Ilyas a little
bit and then you'd come back I was
competing and then you were just around
for whatever reason and then yeah I just
started training with you I think that's
that's when we opened victory
yes there's around the same time yeah
yeah exactly
and then um yeah what was funny is that
you never came off like once like like
knew you like immediately you never came
off as this super intense person like it
was more like you were just sarcastic
like well let you know like any other
like any other of my friends but you
could still always tell that there are
something behind the scenes you know you
know Jorgen said like he's seen you and
he was like there's this guy you know
this I kind of got that same feeling but
you were always just like oh yeah this
real matter-of-fact but fun funny like
kind of person whatever like but when I
say matter of fact I mean like um like
that one this one tournament when it was
kind of later where I lost to Sean
Roberts he got me with a gogoplata you
know when you lose in jiu-jitsu Tran
and that was the first time I lost in
since I went advanced you know because I
was doing a lot of noogie I had never
lost in Sean Roberts keeps me with a
gogoplata so instead of you saying hey
you know it's okay hey or nothing like
that you send me a text you're sitting
across the arena you're right there you
send me texting hey you got caught with
a go-go that's gotta sting I was like
aha whatever but I think that um that
you know training together and just kind
of getting you know you you kind of had
that thing that you could say that kind
of stuff because really it's not that
serious you know yeah when I don't think
I don't think there's there's not many
people who could have conveyed that
though you know it came I think you had
to come from you anyway so yeah that's
kind of how we met I'd say and then um
kind of after a while how did the idea
of a podcast come up because we we kind
of talked about that a little bit before
I kind of forget the formation but it
was in my mind when I went on Joe
Rogan's I think we had talked about a
you know we should do something I think
you said to me like hey well you should
do it and so when I went on Joe Rogan's
and he said you should do a podcast I
think what Tim Ferriss said hey you
should do a podcast and then I kind of
be you being a techy sound guy video guy
I just said hey do you know how to make
a podcast
that's right I just said hey how do you
know how to make a podcast I need to
make one yeah because everything is just
a total caveman right yeah how do you do
I need a tape recorder what do I need
you know that's what my and so then you
said yeah I know I I know how to do that
I could make that happen and then you
said it'd be cool instead of just you
sitting there talking if you had someone
to talk to and I said yeah you're right
that would be cool and then you'd said
you'd be cool if it was me yeah well my
selling point was that strange if it's
just you right just sitting there you
know it's it's more strange and it's
better if you have someone to kind of
bounce things off of especially someone
who can kind of be like whoa I'm just
everyday guy like so I can like ask
questions that kind of reiterate the
point right just someone who might not
get it yeah I had it all thought out you
know in my mind I did anyway um but yeah
then yeah obviously Joe okay now was
kind of the tipping point when he
suggested it yeah yeah I know that was a
good great insight from Joe Rogan and
I'm glad he did and I'm glad you did I'm
glad we did make this podcast happen so
to answer the question what have I
learned and this is interesting because
I asked myself this exact same question
like a week ago because I am literally a
different person now in ways that kinda
are kind of surprising in a way so I'd
say the first thing that's kind of kind
of not that surprising but it'sit's very
prevalent is when people blame when I
see people blaming other people or
blaming me or I feel the compulsion to
blame someone else it stands out like a
sore thumb
almost like if if I've been feeling that
and it like almost like if I want to say
something to indicate that I'm gonna
blame somebody or something it's almost
like a red flag like I'm not allowed to
do that in my own mind it's like it's
hard and fast rule and like I said they
just stand out like a sore thumb
everywhere though on TV you know the guy
not even my conversation oh I see what
you doing right there you know so it's
like it's like your whole way of life in
that regard is just shifted extreme
ownership and the awareness of that yeah
seeing it in other people or lack of it
and other people it definitely stands
out like crazy
once you start thinking about it yeah
and I have the luxury of being around
you talking about these things talking
about examples of it every week right so
throughout the week I'm like I can't
even help but notice it you know and
it's Fred it helps men because it
applies to everyone
they've been everything like most
relationships are gonna apply these
principles you know if you're involved
in them so yeah it's all automatic now
so so when it comes to ownership and
really blaming myself if anyone and
focusing on my responsibility in any
scenario whatever it comes to automatic
now I would say so huge step I mean
whether I make the right choices that's
always gonna be working product progress
I think but as far as that attitude it's
automatic no that's awesome
and then um in regards to okay so I've
always been into working out and so me
not feeling like working out is I've
always felt like working out so as far
as not feeling like it that wasn't
really a factor but in a bunch of other
things in life it was a factor and so so
you're saying we not feeling like doing
thanks um y-z yeah like oh I got it
I gotta go to the post office today and
that's on the low end and then or the
other one is I don't know I don't know
something more important right but maybe
I'll wait I'll wait til really the last
minute or you know procrastination type
stuff so you're getting into the here
and now yeah and not feeling like it
that means absolutely absolutely nothing
something needs to be done and I don't
feel like it and you know how like you
have you have certain ideas already
and then other ideas are introduced and
then those ideas kind of mingle with
your existing ideas and they formulate
this whole new course of action right so
the not feeling like it is no excuse
that idea came in and so now I'm like it
morphed into this thing like me not
feeling I could who guess what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do it so it's almost like
this personal challenge now you know and
man as far as results go and you get
everything done I eat so much stuff done
and it's not so probably compared to
youth
nothing but I get stuff done like so so
many things done during the day that I
never thought that I could do that many
things in a day that's all I was always
looking for maybe arrests or a nap or
something like that but now everyone's
gonna all be challenging myself to do as
many things as I can and be like solid
and on top of that and you're the one
who said this was um one time one of the
things you were kind of tired and you
were like you know what but I like this
I like just grinding and grinding and
grinding and then at the end of the day
when I go and go to bed where my head
just crashes into the pillow I like that
I was like yeah that sounds nice
you know so when I approach things like
that now and also I think of all the
good things that have been done like
great things and just good things or
whatever if these people didn't do it
because they didn't feel like it like
these things when they got done you know
so you got stuff to do you do it whether
you feel like it or not that's what I
don't have for myself now and the last
thing is I kind of knew this but man
it's so clear now that you can get
certain messages and information and
tips and tactics and stuff from from
people or the internet or books or
whatever but if you're not ready to
accept them you just won't accept them
or they'll just go in one ear and out
the other and a lot of time that has to
do with who's saying it so if like I
don't know your neighbor some goof-off
he's drinking a beer smoking a cigarette
is okay guess what you know you should
do this and it's it can be this great
advice for you can be like I'm not gonna
listen to you I'm not even listening to
you I'm not even get past that part the
fact that you're the one that's saying
this already walled me off from what you
have to say and that's natural I think
but a lot of these things like you're
reading these old books that have these
messages that you've been saying so it's
not new stuff and a lot of stuff I heard
that take responsibility for your
actions yeah how's that yeah that's not
new you know if I busts out a hey you
guy on the street take responsibility
for your actions if something comes up
I'm just saying he'd be like yeah that's
nothing new I wouldn't stand out but for
some reason when you're saying it
it gets you thinking yeah let me take
responsibility
so that's so yeah it's a when it comes
to listening to you this podcast all the
you know the answers you have for these
questions and any questions I even have
it seems like it comes and I process it
way more readily then you know memes on
Facebook or wherever yeah so yeah that's
awesome pretty trend that's that's
really cool that's that's great to hear
and I've I mean I've definitely seen a
transition in everything you're doing I
mean everything you're doing is spot-on
yeah and that's legit you know it's it's
legit to see it's legit to see someone
moving towards their potential as a
human yeah that's awesome to see yeah
and another thing that kind of I came to
as not a conclusion but it which is a
result it's not a direct like you didn't
tell me this but this is what all my
existing thoughts mixed with all your
input kind of arrived at one of the
things is that it's up to you it's up to
me what I spend my time doing totally up
to me and it's up to me what I feel my
fill my head with so you know I used to
have these shows that I loved why I love
to watch Hawaii five-o and shark tank
and that's kind of it I don't really
watch that much TV but those do that's
maybe you know two hours or so that I
could be reading something that's gonna
help me through the rest of my life or
getting better at something that's gonna
help my you know relationships or career
or something like that and I use that
example because that seems pretty pretty
like not inconsequential inconsequential
could because it's only two shows it's
not like I spent 10 hours a day watching
TV it's just to show so there's no harm
in that right but it's that's up to me
I'm not missing out by missing Hawaii
five-o not missing out that's not gonna
affect my life in any negative way in
the future at all I don't want to affect
my life in any way actually but if I
read something useful educate myself in
you know whatever arena that's gonna
prove my interest or my or my
relationship or something like that that
will that will help me
ya know either I've that's one of the
things I've noticed in our show up show
up at the studio and you'd say I was
reading this book today about you know
how we could get this to sound better
and I read this thing about you know
you're coming back and with all this
information and it was something that
just transitioned in your brain where
you said you know what I could be
watching TV in wasting my mind or I
could be applying myself and learning
yeah and that's that makes a huge
difference
rather well one of the things I read
actually and I read it on what I want to
say Wikipedia this specific thing but
there's this this automatic way of
thinking and it's called hyperbolic
discounting right and all that it all
that means is you choose immediate
payoffs versa and I kind of mentioned
this before choosing media payoffs
versus long-term payoffs right and it's
there for a reason survival mechanism
and all these ways but it's old it
exists for an you know an environment
that's not current so if you can
basically a be aware that and combat
that where don't do the immediate payoff
things so just take take what you're
about to do evaluate it is this gonna
help me other than the pleasure that I
see whether that in regards to food
drinking TV shows like if you watch a
reality TV check yourself on down and
ask yourself is this gonna help me in
the future and typically that and that
the answer for those types of things are
gonna be no and then consider an
alternative that you can do and a lot of
the stuff can be pleasurable that will
help you in the future
and it's totally up to you it's totally
up to you why not make the good choice
yeah and the payoff not only is it
bigger it lasts longer yeah
and the immediate payoff is gone it's
just a memory